a mysterious illness affecting children
thought to be tied to the coronavirus
is now blamed for at least three deaths
dozens of other patients have contracted
it
senior medical correspondent dr tara
narula looks at the new concern for a
population
thought to be less at risk
this does not present as a normal
covered
case covert cases tend to be respiratory
this it presents as an inflammation of
the blood vessels
a warning from new york governor andrew
cuomo as the state investigates at least
85
cases of what many are calling pediatric
multisystem
inflammatory syndrome officials say it
has killed at least
three children in new york in many cases
children did not have
respiratory issues instead experiencing
abdominal symptoms
change in skin color or chest pain what
we're seeing is the immune system is
actually going into overdrive
impacting the body in a negative way
some of these patients
are having inflammation of their
coronary arteries and you can have
basically a heart attack dr jay
kleinmahn is a pediatric cardiologist
at oxner hospital for children he has
already treated several children for
this illness
including twelve-year-old juliet daily
we spoke to juliet
and her mother last week about her
harrowing trip to the hospital
her heart was not functioning her heart
was inflamed
so badly that the conduction system was
not working in her heart so it was
barely pumping
she was in heart failure hospitals in at
least six states have reported seeing
similar cases
the illness is so concerning new york
city issued a health alert about it last
week
if you're not really aware of um
the syndrome that's that's being
described it could easily
easily be missed fortunately children
overall
are very resilient in almost all the
cases and if we're able to knock down
the inflammation and get them
past the beginning stages of this
they're usually doing very well
experts say this illness bears some
resemblance to a rare condition called
kawasaki disease governor cuomo says his
state's health department will work with
the cdc
and the new york genome centers to study
the illness
tara this is so scary how rare is this
and what should parents be looking for
well anthony i do think it's important
to stress that in the grand scheme of
the pandemic this is rare we're still
learning a lot more about it but the
important thing for parents
is if their child does have but
prolonged high fever abdominal pain
nausea vomiting diarrhea
change in the color of their skin or
their lips or chest pain
that's something they should act on
quickly because in many of these cases
the kids have decompensated or
deteriorated very quickly so important
to call your doctor if you notice any of
those
dr tara narila thanks tara